love guy is looking at the girl and the  girls looking at the guy the guy thinks  that she's attractive and the girl  thinks that she is he's attractive  and I guess they think love at first  height looks very funny and the girl  looks like jack-in-the-box it's just a  guy and a girl and there's art and  someone else like so and someone like  someone else a little bit happy face cuz  you're happier than like fuzzies because  you kind of feel and I drew on the side  like enjoyable things that you might  like love to do or something love makes  me feel kind of like just one big happy  thing so I drop like a lot of happy  stuff in my life that like I really like  in my life a picture of my mom a rainbow  I thought I'm gonna draw my own pics  I love my mom that one I wore cast resin  when you have love it's basically like a  warm feeling so I kind of pictured like  a teddy bear hugging you like a huge  Convergys hugging hill when you feel up  like expression